es ist wirklich braucht nicht sagen da
wahrscheinlich eine familie favoriten
oder schon mal ist es geht doch die tour
habe ich auch selber bevor die
eigentliche bühne
sehr stark von der umgang mit mehr und
mit dem ganzen umfeld auch was man
schwierige sachen zweisprachige hat
natürlich bestens ganzen vorteil dabei
die unbedingt sie achtet urologie am
hang turnier bittersüß indoors basel wo
alles wirklich darum hat diese sowie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herbst 2017 ein jahr lang begleiten der
bernhard scheer
eben noch in basel nun bereits in london
beim nächsten tennis highlight heute
gibt's kein sieger interview auch ein
superstar zieht mal einen schlechten tag
ein
ich habe heftig
seit über 20 jahren begleitet er mit
seiner stimme die karriere von roger
federer auf sf1 heißt der bernhard
scheer
3 burley scheer mit ausnahme der
australian open hat der 62-jährige
sämtliche grand slam titel des schweizer
tennis das live miterlebt seine arbeit
sei ein großes privileg findet er
respekt und fairness zu bewahren
unabhängig vom resultat dies gehöre zum
credo seiner journalistischen arbeit
was ist passiert wird gaddafi koffer
editas beurteile die situation besser
aus also ich will auch geschossen das
sie ist ein schnelllebiges der hektische
zeit in der schwarz weiß dominiert dass
er endlich habe ich sehr gut oder sich
große schlacht ja immer probiert es
blieb die stanzt objektiv die situation
beurteilen und du das denn viele mieter
wohl begraben hat aber ohnehin extrem
timo glock kazakhmys mit dumas wenn der
tenniszirkus in australien und übersee
halt macht wechselt bernisch er auf den
schnee
die lauberhornrennen gehören fix zu
seinem jahresprogramm
auch hier setzt bernie scheer heute auf
einen schweizer sieg aus
[Musik]
bei tagesanbruch ein kurzer blick auf
die bergkulisse und bereits steht die
erste live schaltung an für srf 3
hallo liebe grad im lift und stiege
jetzt die lüftung der machen es vom lift
super
judith kirschke so sehr gut sehr gut je
unvorhersehbarer umso besser für
burne-jones kurz judith hoersch wenn
jetzt fahrer das geeignete so war das
schon okay wir machen musste war
bilderbuchwetter das hammer sagte kaiser
wetter also müsse die kulisse jetzt
eigentlich jung froh wäre sogar vom bsz
ev prof es ist super unterwegs führt vor
200 leuten muss sich das vorstellen
die mutter am morgen am für die abfahrer
in scheidung und erwarte der top-favorit
fritz natürlich ein extremist
unterstützer liu die dankeschön die
später zu youtube top-qualität
studioqualität es authentisch
[Musik]
augsburg dpa afx glücklich machen wir
immer noch
zwar holten sich hoch motiviert
abgefahren
hier konnte betreten noch bleibt
macht riskiert kennt man sich rocco zu
üben wenn es mal nicht aber das gehört
mit zum credo sie die ohren das einfach
vor trennen die piste besichtigung
machen einen unstillbaren
informationshunger habe er die eindrücke
auf der piste und von den trainingstagen
zuvor liefern ihn zusätzlichen stoff für
die langen live sendungen alles gut
alles tiptop und heute wer erfolg hat
ford das highlight und das große fest in
längen zurück um barmittel
ausgangssperre für verwirrte berlin
kilometer pro stunde und jetzt in
steelers stürmer luis fabiano von lüder
europäer über syrien sie die
virtualisierte mit dem zielsprung
ungarisch im ziel mit den erste
richtzeit vor zwei minuten und satte
20,5 sekunden
der wertvolle jetzt aber uhr trotz der
zur show winkt aber beatrice pumpen du
bist echt fantastisch heute mach so
weiter hamm werne gibt 100 prozent wie
sieht dabei rascher motivation hat
solche gratulation b hat will man das
ganz aus
jetzt folgt was bernisch er am liebsten
macht das sieger interview mit einem
schweizer sportler die bewunderung ist
gegenseitig und was mich fasziniert dann
hätten jährigen frau wie zb hier drehen
und nichts wie raus aus dem rathaus
einfach ausgetauscht gedacht das war's
schon im skisport das ist auch im tennis
sowieso irgendwo was genau auskennt noch
die weltcups bis sechs rennen noch nicht
mehr von chase fachkompetenz profitiert
auch sohn jonas der aktuelle u 18
schweizer meister im tennis
er wird immer doppelspitze mit dem
effekt dass perfektes er wieso genau so
für einen rhythmus die tenniskarriere
von jonas ist ein familienprojekt
[Musik]
häufiger als bei roger federer verpasst
bernie scheer ein tennisturnier seines
sohnes nicht so heute jonas spielt die
norden
zwei berufstätige eltern und ein
ambitionierter sohn das erfordert
teamwork
ich kann nicht anders man sie bei diesem
unregelmäßiger schlaf liegt mit dem
jonas
also begleitete kann ich mich schlechter
als core tonnen und für den fachlichen
micro dass ich chancen besitzt auch das
mit besonders von krems begleiten
solange sich mit hänger main ev aussage
pro karte aus dem fck nach der e10 ist
jonas etwas aber nicht weil sie um
machen
vor der matura machen trainiert battery
case bäumer und hedwig den spaß am
spezialist
[Applaus]
jonas gewinnt inzwischen sogar
internationale turniere wie optimierte
eine durchdachte warten noch auf konter
und geht's in die praxen zeigten auf was
eine urkunde eine schlacht macht was
eindruck muss das angepasst
das erkannt und in etwa drei uhr morgens
heute heißt es frühschicht in zürich
damals alle frühaufsteher
januar sensix motorfahrzeuge banken etwa
das war mit sehr für unannehmlichkeiten
für kunden wie credit and stupid und ob
tagen zieht und wach ist und den 870 auf
ca
also bis jetzt kann es geschafft die
augen übertrieb ski rechtzeitig wieder
im studio sie draußen oder im studio
egal wie schwer ist mit feuereifer dabei
und auf den punkt startklar im tennis
bleibt roger federer im deutschen halle
weiterhin auf erfolgskurs
ja das hört dem ort gemacht habe ja
natürlich inhaltlich shop ist uwe
marquardt fahrer basiert und so gewinnt
man natürlich deutlich zieht er von
argentinien rigoros ausgenutzt wenn ist
auch gestorben sein
das mache ich erfahren dann tot war
nicht drin
das hatte die zeigt die frage thomas
schopf sr bernd wort freestyle und dein
limit
ich glaube es ist natürlich sorgt sieht
als sie angefangen vertriebsgebiet am
gebäude
da ist heute telex sehe warum hätte
abgerissen und tiefgang hat den wander
und gemälde so zusammengefasst hat
passiert das aus elektronisch dazu hatte
die social media reaktionen dass sie mit
involviert unterhaltsamer komplexe aber
interessanter und so dass es noch mal
richtig fordert gar kein schloss vom
inneren ratenkredits iwf rückt und eine
harmlose west für fabian unteregger der
berni parodiert hat er schon fast
kultstatus durch die wiederum bilden
jedes mal wimbledon noch in gips 20 18
in dienst kommen damit sich dagegen dies
sei jetzt wahr ist wäre der schock setzt
ob die erste sekunde wurden am radio
kurt müller trotzdem das waren die
unnötigen mit dem ganze paket energie
über den grund und ich glaube das ist so
geil von der dna von bernstein am radio
trotzdem deklassiert argentinien nahm
nach knapp mit 1 0 und zeigte alles in
allem es starke teamleistung und hebt
sie der zweikampf es gibt gewisse regeln
im radio modelle gibt es auch darüber
dass und meistens ist schon auf deine
auf der regler wieder bier vertagung
spontan und die leidenschaft und der
mannschaft parat sie und dabei immer gut
und das ist das tolle daran ist
das schaffen wir
bernie im glück
an keinem anderen tennis anlass blüht
der 62-jährige so auf wie in wimbledon
dies nicht nur weil roger federer hier
bereits achtmal gewonnen hat dws als
erwartet hier 22 uhr tägliche position
von center court zur klasse hält wo die
akkus strahlt das ist gleich bleiben
es ist die hektik und ist vor allem
attribut ausstand und fairplay und
respekt voreinander dominieren
eigentlich je weiter wo ja der roger
federer in den winterwald vom tennis
tour für körper und das ist auch der
grund warum das kein italiener konter
und wimmelte es ist mit abstand liebstes
turnier bezeichnet
in den jahren sind auch viele
freundschaften entstanden wie die zur
robert federer als möglicher gäste aus
hätte der supporter van der beek soja
und aber regina k s sie geben lobt der
ganze turm und am schluss
ich sehe damit dieses vertrauen hat auf
dem rott ihm eine junge jahre und mit
tritten an allen grand slams es ist
einfach toll mit dem team ein
betreffendes regelmäßiger ich bin halb
schon wie sie stunden vor dem match
nehmen sie ein junge
das spricht gerne den ist ein raser
möglichkeit an den mängeln zurecht als
insel male auffällig geht immer mein
name ist die mutter dem vater müssen
dann immer beschützen und mannheim
dies bietet sich vor allem auch an den
tagen an wenn auf der anlage trainiert
roger federer ist doch bernisch er im
herbst seiner karriere
spätestens in zwei jahren soll schluss
sein
dies weiß man auch im umfeld von roger
federer
[Gelächter]
gratulation
die ganze team tony godsick wenig kunst
von dennis ich mich als trainer jetzt
sollten sie gut 82 dann turnier zu
finden
das erfolgt über den eingang ist doch
wunderbar worden
ja ich gerne noch in der nächsten
generation so radio superstar
das ist genau das was ich mache aber
biete nimmt derzeit noch auf das leben
oder für die familie und das ist einfach
nicht einschlafen anziehen
und ich glaube die nächsten zwei jahren
engagiert besten sie verschiedene
karriere überzeugt und ich will wo wir
so lange will aber leider nicht mit dem
bernischen gerade ganze situation
bernhard berni spezieller stimme das
schweizer tennis geprägt für die
radiolegende wird der tennissport
mittelpunkt bleiben in seinem leben aber
ganz im kreis der familie mit ehefrau
ursula und junior schutzbarriere sehr
schnell bewegt ist dass gauck nicht
rechtzeitig vor einem media heimen
entschuldigen so wie jetzt sehr viel
wert ist verdanken wir das sehr schöne
zeit ganz von berlin auf dass man sich
gemeinsam mit hinterhand
das natürlich auch das eigentlich ferien
etwas möglich für die hand weil jetzt
der unterschiedlich ferien wenig und ist
als freie museum ja dass man wirklich
mitzieht für den anhand weniger in
stresssituationen und laune entscheiden
wird gott wo wir und stress diesen tanz
in ruhe tarif oder gar nichts ahnen mit
dem und einfach hinterher mit sie aus
familie und praxis gratulieren
das genauso ich muss spielen dies spürte
die cs